The ghouls and freaks
are on the prowl.
I need sweets and treats to stop
my stomach growl.
I haven't thrown a
Halloween party...
in a minute!
I want this to be one
for the history books.
You understand me?
You know my Halloween queen will
be throwing this party with me.
I'll pick the best
baking talent.
I want dozens and
dozens of treats.
I want a fortress of fondant!
Everything I do has to be big.
Ha ha ha!
Welcome to our Tasty Manor.
Oh!
Ready to make my Halloween
nightmares a reality?
Ha ha ha!
Halloween is one of
my favorite holidays.
Are you up to it?
Yes! Yes!
From Buzzfeed's "Tasty,"
Alvin Zhou!
That is insane.
This is the most crazy baking
kitchen I've ever been in.
It takes a lot to
meet my expectations.
Boy do I know!
Ha ha ha!
No more wasting time.
Ready to have some fun?
Oh, that's spooky!
Really creepy.
I'm just shocked that so
much of this is edible.
Everything is edible!
Get out of there Alvin!
Heh, they got Snoop's fingers.
What is going on, man?!
That is our chocolate gateau.
Oh, let's see what this
ghetto chocolate's working with.
You said you wanted a party.
Snoop, you're slouching.
She's the only one that
can train this Dogg.
Ha ha ha!